Our Draft annual plan for 2017/2018 is out now and we want to hear what you think.
We’re reorganised the budget for our capital
works programme – so we can prioritise
the completion of several major projects and
prepare for future developments.
Find out what’s happening with your rates.
On average rates increases are lower than
previously indicated; however there are some areas
that have experienced large gains in capital value or
are undertaking major water supply upgrades.
Tell us how we’re tracking with the management
of our natural environment – this encompasses
our waterways, storm water drains and ocean
outfall.
And have your say on whether our district’s
shops should have the option
of trading on Easter Sunday.
So, let’s talk.
You can view the plan and make your submission
online or at any of our service centres.
Visit Waimakariri.govt.nz to find out more
and have your say.